un llamado por ayuda humanitaria cientos
de migrantes a los que se les impidió
desembarcar en Italia protestan desde el
barco de rescate geovarens de bandera
Noruega las autoridades solo permitieron
el desembarque a menores familias y
personas con problemas médicos un total
de 357 personas
215 quedaron a bordo
por el momento las personas que se
quedan atrás sin desembarcar
no sabemos qué va a pasar no hemos
recibido más instrucciones
algunas organizaciones internacionales
rescatan a inmigrantes que quedan
varados en su travesía desde el norte de
África hasta Europa mientras piden a los
gobiernos que acepten a los inmigrantes
dentro de su territorio el nuevo
gobierno italiano de Georgia meloni ha
decidido mantener su política de Puerto
cerrados mientras en los barcos aumenta
la desesperación el riesgo de
propagación de infecciones respiratorias
y los alimentos y suministros médicos se
agotan
tres migrantes bloqueados en un barco
decidieron lanzarse al agua antes de ser
rescatados
por eso el derecho internacional
Establece que las personas deben ser
desembarcadas lo más rápido posible en
un lugar seguro para evitar lo que está
pasando ahora el barco tiene sus límites
en cuanto a la asistencia médica un
barco es como una ambulancia y en la
ambulancia siempre hay gente gente
la comisión europea recordó al gobierno
italiano que los estados miembros tienen
el deber moral y la obligación legal de
rescatar a los migrantes en el mar
independientemente de las circunstancias
en las que hayan llegado allí